saint cyr l'école veut faire briller sa
cité des nombreux jeunes du quartier
gérard philipe ont participé au
nettoyage de leur lieu de vie avec un
sac poubelle à la main des gants et la
volonté de protéger l'environnement
ils ont ramassé de nombreux déchets
c'est important parce que nous on veut
que l'environnement il reste intacte
qu'il n'y a pas de défauts qui a pas de
pollution
donc on est là on est dans ce match et
ça c'est plutôt cool hein c'est arrêter
de polluer à respecter sa ville haute et
j'ai l'environnement c'est ne pas
l'abîmer
cette opération nettoyage s'inscrit dans
le défi m'a cité va briller lancé par
des quartiers de garges les gonesse dans
le val d'oise à saint-cyr-l'ecole
l'association audace a lancé
l'initiative accompagnés par les
colibris
c'est important aspect positif en
général quand on parle des quartiers
cette chose à ce qu'un peu négatif et là
c'est une bonne chose que les propres
jeunes de leurs propres quartiers
prennent l'initiative pour essayer
d'améliorer leur quartier tout
simplement
l'association audace en oeuvre pour les
jeunes de ce quartier un accompagnement
sportif culturel et social connu par la
municipalité
c'est des jeunes que je connais un que
je vois tout au long de l'année et
aujourd'hui je contente de les voir se
sont mobilisés pour un pour un beau
challenge
et qu'est ce qu'on en dit je pense
qu'ils sont tous complètement conscient
après c'est toujours pareil c'est
le geste individuel qui est compliqué
c'est le changement de mentalité et
c'est la tradition pour ma cité va
briller le quartier gérard philipe a
lancé le défi à une autre ville laissant
syrien en nommer et fontenay le fleury
[Musique]